i'd like to do something practical i had
something to do with sport
um i like football in the dream we'll
probably football player
because i play that i like it but it's a
very small chance of happening
you've got any kind of people you'd look
up to outside of football no
no beyond football
aspiration is a problem here at outward
grange academy in workshop
a town with high unemployment since the
pits closed in the 1990s
to explore the factors of race and class
in education we're starting here we
decided to track the attainment
of white british pupils to another group
those from a black african origin
from primary school to year 7 to gcse
their attainment levels are roughly the
same but take that same group and focus
just on those poorer kids on free school
meals
the black african children the blue line
is a bit below the wealthier kids
but the purple line the white working
class starts very low
and the gap just gets wider towards
gcses
so what's happening the issues arise
because of low aspirations from students
and when i first arrived and i talked to
some students about where they could go
and the jobs they could do
they would look at me and say well why
would i want to work my dad doesn't work
and my grandfather doesn't work why
would i want a job
in five years dr smith managed to turn
outward grange around from being in
special measures to being in the top 10
schools in england for student
progression
but he met resistance the families were
angry
because i was taking him away from them
and they'd expected their child to live
on that street
forever and now the child was saying i
want to go to university
so it's it's a different view fenton
hopes to be the first of his family to
go to university
he believes it's not just aspiration but
that his town doesn't get the investment
of more multicultural inner cities like
london i think it's been just the lack
of funding that we get
naturally in london costa living's
higher they've got a lot more money in
general
whereas you sort of get to that
north-south divide and the north has got
very little in terms of resource and we
sort of make do what we've got
so poor white children are struggling
but black students have a different
battle and it comes later
at a level white students from all
backgrounds overtake students from a
black african origin
and at university the difference widens
with white students achieving better
degrees
five years after graduating white people
are more likely to be in sustained
employment or further education
and are earning more money melts a phd
student at cambridge
believes that as you move up the
education ladder it becomes more racist
in my entire three years studying i
never once
read somebody that wasn't white in my
philosophy side of my degree
i'll flick a page and then i'll be
reading about something they're saying
black people are less than human that
like literally you feel like you don't
belong here
do i feel like i don't belong here i
um no i don't feel like i belong here
and a sense of belonging in the
education system
is a crucial factor black working class
youngsters face barriers so do white
working-class youngsters
we tend to either talk about class
separately as though that's the thing
with white people
and then we talk about racism as though
that's only a thing with
black people but actually race and class
interact
and actually both of these factors
compound the life chances of our young
people at the moment
the data tells a clear story that
ethnicity
and poverty form barriers in education
that we're still yet to break jason
farrell sky news